high pressure pumps wash out the sand
containing titanium
work processes haven't changed much here
at the earshones mine but the owners
have changed
the mine was leased to oligarch dimitri
futas until the fall of 2014.
then the ukrainian government cancelled
the contract
it's work as usual same as always so far
everything is peaceful
titanium from the mine is in demand
around the world
it's a high quality resource that's used
for airplane engines customers include
airbus boeing and the russian aviation
industry
the factory's facilities are completely
outdated there's been no new machinery
since the 1990s
little changed after firtas took over in
2004
he also invested very little
that means the plant is in a constant
state of disrepair
the younger workers especially
want change now
they kept everything running but
invested nothing
we'd like to modernize the production
lines we need new machines and new
concepts in order to work efficiently
we need new shakers
new pipes
new everything
this is the austrian capital vienna and
a long way away from the problems
it's home to dimitri fertosh
for months he refused to accept that
he'd lost the mine
but he says he's changed his mind now
it's no problem for me
i've got two other minds and they
provide all the raw materials i need
is a controversial figure
he's been indicted in the united states
on corruption charges
the u.s authorities want him extradited
a vienna court released him on bail of
125 million euros the largest in
austrian history
fiertas is trying to improve his image
he's financing an initiative to support
economic reform in ukraine
to be honest ukraine is bankrupt we've
got two options
do something or wait
i think we need to carry out reforms
that the government isn't implementing
former german finance minister pere
steinbrueck is among his supporters
as is the former french foreign minister
bernard kushner
ex-european commissioner gunther farhoyn
is another advisor
they all want reform for the ukrainian
economy and they're putting their
contacts to use
it's unclear how much the oligarch is
paying them
is but it's a fact that this circle of
advisors is completely independent it
isn't subject to controls and it's not
under the influence of any large-scale
industrialists or oligarchs who have
been active in ukraine
nobody from the ukrainian government
attended the forum in vienna despite
that the advisors hope kiev will take
notice of their reform suggestions
and they don't believe modernization
will happen without the oligarchs
independent of reflect on
very specific economic issues
those people who have grown rich in
ukraine in the past 20 years should use
their wealth to play a role in
reconstruction
we want them to provide money for
different projects and this is one of
them
project
the ukrainian government intends to
privatize the earshan's mind and has no
plans to use advisors sponsored by
feartosh
we have a new parliament and fiertas
doesn't have enough people there to
regain influence
but despite losing the titanium mines
dimitri futas still has a hundred
thousand employees in ukraine alone